>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> This is now-- guess what?
How many-- how many-- okay.
This is like my first
week of school.
This is my first week being here.
I've got a job here now.
>> What?
>> Yeah. I've got a job.
And guess what, I like it.
Because I'm a librarian.
[inaudible] No, no.
I don't want to work anywhere else.
You know why?
No. Because I'm a librarian.
[inaudible]
>> -- my daddy's house.
>> Oh. No.
I'm a librarian, and I love books.
[inaudible] I love-- yes I do.
[inaudible] Yeah.
How many of you have
books at your house?
>> I have 100!
[ Shouting ]
>> Okay, now this is
a hard question.
This is a hard question.
You got to listen.
[inaudible] Okay, that's easy.
But this is a hard one.
How many of you have a library card?
Mm-hmm.
>> I have one library-- well, I--
>> One library card.
You can only-- well, sometimes
you can have more than one.
Okay. Because you could even
have a library card here.
Did they tell you about this book
and why we're so excited
about coming?
Not only is this my third time here,
and I really wanted to be here,
it's also a chance to
share a book with you
that I just found out about.
I knew about the Click-Clack--
how many of you--
>> Moo!
>> Click-Clack Moo, yeah.
I knew about--
>> I read it at our school.
>> You've had that at your school?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
At your house.
[multiple speakers] I know, I know!
I know! Click-Clack Moo.
I knew all about that.
But I didn't know about this book.
>> Is this the same author?
>> It's the same author.
See? I think it's a series they
call it-- where it's Click-Clack--
because when you like a book a lot,
you want another one just like it.
So this is Click-Clack Surprise.
And guess what the surprise is?
What's this look like?
>> The cow's birthday!
>> Birthday!
Now, how many birthdays-- okay.
I've had a lot of birthdays.
>> Me too.
>> Yeah.
>> How old are you?
>> Yeah, I've had a
lot of birthdays.
>> How old are you?
[inaudible]
>> I should make you guess, but I'm
not, because I don't think you've--
know that many numbers yet.
[multiple speakers] Okay.
Who's 5?
>> Me!
>> I'm 4.
>> Four, five-- you're five?
>> I'm four and a half.
[multiple speakers]
>> Any sixes?
Do we have any sixes?
Six?
>> I'm six.
>> Six? Any sevens?
>> I'm five.
>> I'm six.
>> Four, four.
>> Well, I'm going to tell
you-- oh, my goodness.
Are you going to make tell
how many birthdays I've had?
>> I'm four and a half.
[multiple speakers]
>> I've had a lot.
I've had six-- I've
had 60 birthdays.
>> Oh, my!
[laughter]
>> Older than my dad!
>> I'm probably older than your
dad; maybe your grandmother.
She's 30-- oh, he's 37.
>> My dad is 43, and my mom's 47.
>> She's 47?
How about grandparents?
Can we read the book?
Because-- I don't-- thank you.
>> My grandma's 77, and
my grandpa's [inaudible].
>> Okay. All right.
Because sometimes as you
get more and more birthdays,
you don't like to talk about it.
So, what-- this book is
about a very first birthday.
Little Duck, and you know about
click-clack, and the farm,
and Farmer Brown, well,
now there's Little Duck.
And Little Duck-- and
they're getting ready
for Little Duck's first birthdays.
And you've had a lot
of birthday parties,
or been to birthday
parties [inaudible] I know!
Little Duck-- first birthday-- has
never been to a birthday party.
>> I have.
>> I know!
You've been to a lot of them.
So, Farmer Brown said,
we're going to give--
>> I've been to three.
>> -- okay, well let's see
what happens when you--
you've never been to a
birthday party, ever, ever,
ever, and it's your first one.
>> I have.
>> And they were getting ready.
Look how they're getting ready.
They're getting ready,
and they're making a cake,
and they're getting the balloons,
and they're doing all this stuff.
They sent out invitations.
Look at that.
Now, you know, this is on the farm,
so all the animals
get an invitation.
>> You're not really reading it.
>> Hmm? Well, you know
why I'm not reading it?
I'm trying to show it to you.
I read it about four
times because I liked it.
And I said I wanted to
know what was going on.
Because, when they sent
out the invitations,
the invitation had what?
The types of games
are going to have.
So first and said pin
the tail on the donkey.
And what did the donkey do?
Cross that out.
No pinning the tail on the donkey.
And then it was duck duck goose.
They were going to play that.
And what did he do?
>> We know that game!
>> You know that game?
Well, duck didn't like
that game, or the goose.
So it was canceled.
>> You race around.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And they do duck, duck--
>> What game do you think this was?
>> Because they do
duck, duck, goose.
>> This game was steal the bacon.
And who didn't like that one?
[inaudible] The pig.
He tried to be anonymous.
>> Because bacon--
>> And--
>> -- is made out of pig!
>> I know.
And the pig didn't want that game.
So here it says everybody wants
to look their best for
Little Duck's party.
And Duck took a long bath.
He rub-a-dubbed, and rub-a-dubbed,
and rub-a-dubbed clean,
and he's walking to the
maple tree because that's
where the parties going to be.
And Little Duck-- hmm-- okay.
Little Duck washes and
then rub-a-dubs too.
All over. Sheep-- the sheep
wanted to look their best,
and they trimmed themselves.
Trim, trim, trim [inaudible] clean.
And then they walked
over to the maple tree.
Little Duck watched and clipped--
clip, clip, clip-- clipped.
>> His hair?
>> Mm-hmm.
[inaudible] Guess who
wanted to look the best?
The cat. Cat wants to look the
best so she slurps, and slurps,
and slurps herself clean.
And then Cat-- [inaudible] I know.
And then Cat walks
to the maple tree.
Little duck watches and
he slurps, and slurps,
and slurps and slurps, and slurps.
Now, the chickens-- the chickens
take a dust bath to look their best.
They take a dust bath and they
shimmy-shake, and they shimmy-shake,
and they shimmy-shake, and
then walk to the maple tree.
Little Duck watches the
chickens, and shimmy-shakes,
and shimmy-shakes, and
shimmy-shakes, and shimmy-shakes.
[inaudible].
Uh-oh. The pigs, they
need a mud bath
to look their best for the party.
[inaudible] So, they
squishy-squash, squishy-squash,
squishy-squash all in the mud.
>> They're getting
dirty for the party.
ready for the party.
There pigs.
And they walked to the maple tree.
And little Duck gets in the mud and
squishes and gets in the mud too.
Well, now the cows, now the
cows like the way they look.
They thought they looked
pretty good.
And so the cows-- no
rub-a-dubbing, no snippity-clipping,
no slurpy-slurpy, no shimmy-shaking,
no squishing and squashing,
they just walk to the maple tree.
Now, Farmer Brown was
making the cake.
And he lights the candles
and he puts on his best hat,
and he walks to the maple tree.
And guess what they start to say?
[singing] Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Little Duck.
[inaudible] That's the birthday boy!
All that--
>> How old is he?
>> He's just one years old!.
He thought that he should do what
all the other animals were doing.
And look how he looks.
At his own birthday--
birthday party.
But you know what?
Everybody was so happy to be there,
they stood with them
and they took pictures--
>> And they ate the cake.
>> -- and they ate the cake.
And later on, the end--
what did he do?
>> Take a bath.
>> He took a bath.
So--
>> He was so dirty and yucky.
>> He was because what did he do?
[inaudible] Good!
So, guess what?
Will you sometimes come
back so we can do-- and I--
this will be my fourth time
the next time you come back.
[inaudible] Good.
Well, look.
I think some people are coming up.
Let's see what they're going to do.
[inaudible]
>> -- you're available to take
questions from the audience?
>> Oh, you want to ask me questions?
I'll ask you questions, too.
Okay. Birthday parties.
Who's been to a birthday
party this summer?
>> I have!
>> Oh, where did you go?
>> Me, Me!
[inaudible]
>> I went to the bowling alley.
>> Oh, nice!
[multiple speakers] The same?
Were you together?
No? Different one?
[multiple speakers]
Where did you go?
>> I went to Jumping
Jo-Jo's [phonetic]
>> Jumping Jo-Jo's?
[multiple speakers] Chuck E. Cheese?
I've heard of Chuck E. Cheese.
Where did you go?
[multiple speakers] Nice.
>> I went to Pump it Up.
>> Pump it Up?
>> And I went to a wrestling place!
>> Wrestling place?
>> Yeah, and wrestled 5-year
olds when I was just 4.
>> Wow. Well, do you want to know
the last-- oh, where did you go?
>> To my own brother's birthday.
>> Your own brother's?
You were at home?
>> And I built his
[inaudible] for him.
>> Oh, that's nice!
You're a good brother.
[multiple speakers] Oh, my!
Does anybody want to know
where I went for my birthday?
[inaudible] You do?
[multiple speakers] I went
to an ice cream store.
I went to an ice cream store,
and I got two dips of chocolate.
Can I tell you a secret?
Well, now everybody's going to know.
I got the ice cream cone,
because I love chocolate.
That's my favorite.
>> I love chocolate.
>> I got two dips.
You like it?
[multiple speakers] All the flavors?
But guess what else I did?
I ordered a milkshake to go.
[inaudible] Yeah, it was something.
>> Me too!
>> You did it too?
Well, I'm just so glad that you
let me come in here with you.
This is my first trip.
I'm going to wait for the
next Click-Clack book.
We'll see what Little Duck does.
He's only one years old now.
And do you know, this author, she's
going to be at our book festival.
Next week, we're going to
have thousands, and thousands,
and thousands of people come with
hundreds and hundreds of books,
and this author is
going to be there.
So maybe she'll read this and the
rest of her Click-Clack stories.
You think?
Good. Well, are you going to--
could you sing that song for me?
Because I just heard iti a
little bit, when I was coming in.
That song.
Do you remember?
You've got to remember it.
What was that song you were singing?
>> Sure. We were singing
a song called [inaudible]
>> Oh.
>> And every time we go, one
of our friends will choose a
movement, and then we all copy it.
>> Can I do it?
>> So, maybe-- could you
help me out with that?
We can-- we could do it together.
>> Okay. Let's do it.
>> So, we're going to sing the song.
You can stay right there.
We'll sing the song, and then when
you see a friend do a movement,
you pick the movement, and
then we'll all follow you.
Sound good?
I know that you'll catch on.
>> Now be--
>> You will catch on.
>> -- no be nice to me, because
I've never done this, okay?
>> Okay, ready guys?
>> So-- you got to help me out.
Okay, so--
[ Singing ]
>> Show Dr. Hayden now.
[inaudible] you pick it.
That's it.
>> Oh, okay.
Good!
[ Singing ]
>> This is hard!
Okay, all right.
[ Singing ]
I think I'm getting it.
>> Everyone do your own way.
Own way. Do your own way.
Pick it.
[ Singing ]
Snap. Snap.
Put in your lap.
Now, Miss [inaudible]
class might have a way
that we always say thank
you or a little celebration
to a special guest
that we might have.
So, friends, why don't we give
Dr. Hayden a looking good cheer.
Are you ready?
>> Oh!
>> Ready? Ready?
[inaudible] ready?
Go. [cheer]
>> All right!
Thank you!
Looking good!
Yes! Oh, thank you.
Can I shake your hand?
[inaudible] I need a hug or two.
I need a hug.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.